i like the delicious feeling of
uncertainty i get in your work
for a long time into game of thrones
when i start with game of thrones there
was a point
i paused almost towards the end where i
thought is
is the magic that people are talking
about actually real in this book because
it's a long while before you see
anything truly supernatural happen like
dragons are born you see there are white
walkers but you think that that that
might not be as supernatural as it
seems the super the supernatural world
really creeps in very subtly at the
edges of the world
and you've got gods in the book as well
oh god's the new gods
the lord of light how real are the gods
is it giving too much away to say how
real the gods are
in the world of westeros well and
how real are the gods in our world um
a lot of people believe they're real a
lot of people have very intense faith in
them
and uh there are people who will swear
that you know prayer works and
certain prophets be it jesus or muhammad
or whoever could work miracles and raise
the dead and walk on water and
you know what have you um are are those
things real or are those things
myths um we don't know and i i
although my work is fantasy and it's set
in an imaginary world
i want to ground it in realism
i i look at the real world and i look at
real history and i
i draw from that uh from my parallels to
hopefully give it the same sort of
varisimilitude there
i certainly don't intend ever to bring a
god on stage
in any of the ice and fire books where
god will certainly
suddenly appear like a genie or
something yeah
there's fantasy that does that but um
[Music]
not mine because again the grounding and
realism here i i don't i don't really
see that happening
in in real life i mean we see
events happening in in the real world
that certain people who have a
religious uh belief ascribe
to their particular god or combination
of gods but it's not provable that
it was that it could have just been some
other explanation
and that's i i like that sort of
ambiguity since it occurs in real life i
i want to
create that ambiguity in my fiction too
so you know when something happens and
some of my characters are
very cynical about the gods be they the
old gods or new gods but there are
other people who are deeply deeply
religious and have a lot of
faith and you know there's a there's a
priest as one of the characters who
follows a deity called the drown god
there's melisandre who's
a um a priestess of um of a
fire deity the uh the lord of light
um and they're you know they're true
believers
uh they ascribe everything to the gods
other characters like
tyrion lannister are far more cynical
about all of this
one of the interesting things about the
way i've structured the books uh
you know i have multiple viewpoint
characters it's a tight
viewpoint structure where i'm
not an omniscient author i don't tell
you the way it really is
i put you in a skin of one of my
characters and you're seeing the world
through that character and you're
hearing his thoughts
but you only know what he knows you only
see what he says you only hear what he
hears
uh and it's all filtered through his own
particular worldview and beliefs
um so george rr martin is not a god in
the song of ice and fire in that sense
not in that sense no what are your
voices in any way not the voice of the
god
and sometimes two characters who are
present at the same event have very
different versions of the same event
of course as you as you find in the real
world uh you know any
any trial attorney will tell you if you
get two eyewitnesses you get two
different
versions of what actually occurred um so
you know i try to include all of that
in in the books there's a lot of moral
anarchy
going on in westeros at the time you
know the wicked tend to get on pretty
well
and good men like you know ned stark die
like dogs
is is that how things is it a
particularly bad time in westeros when
you're writing in your mind
or is this how things always are in this
medieval world
well uh you know i think you you look
through
the history of westeros and there are
there are periods of peace and
prosperity
um but then it's it's not like this is
the first time they've ever had a civil
war
or the first time they've ever had uh
these sort of political machinations and
murders and poisonings and so forth
that occurs all through history just as
it does all through real history there
is such an absence of justice
it seems specifically is this the time
though is this is this how it is
is this part of winter is coming is this
this is the kind of climate setting the
kind of moral climate in the world
well um first of all the story is not
finished of course the ice and fire
story so
we'll have to see where things stand at
the end of it but um
you know i've i've drawn a lot on real
history
um i've twisted it and turned it and
you know added fantasy elements and
combined elements of it
but still the grounding is in real
history and
particularly medieval history the wars
of the roses the crusades the
the albigensian crusade the hundred
years war
and if you look through those periods
that you you don't see a lot of uh what
you would call justice there either
either you see uh um unending
successions of of murders and battles
and
people lying to each other and betraying
each other and uh
um you know all this all this uh human
drama
being played out with uh with crowns in
the hazard
and uh life and death on the line
i i notice uh that uh given the uh
the medieval flavor of these books i
just wonder if you'd like to kind of
imagine yourself what life would have
been like in the middle ages with
you know with most people's lives they
wouldn't have got wanted much beyond
their own village
the only thing they'd hear all day would
be birdsong or
wind through the trees the only image
they'd ever see would be an icon in
church at the end of the week is that
something you try to
try to think about when you're writing
well i'd certainly try to keep
you know what i know about the the real
middle ages in in mind
it is fantasy so i could change elements
but i think you have to be very careful
when you change things you have to
you have to think about every change you
make you can't do it i
i mean i read a lot of fantasy too and i
i love fantasy
when it's done right there's a lot of it
that's not done right that
while they adopted trappings of the
middle ages it's sort of a disneyland
middle ages where they have castles and
princesses and nights but they don't
it's there's no depth there it's it's
very uh
shallow um
the real middle ages was a tough time to
live i
i mean you know the historians have
especially the early middle ages
historians have moved away from
calling it the dark ages as we used to
call it which i think is a pity because
the dark ages were a better name for it
than
the early middle ages which is one of
these you know politically correct
things we don't want to offend any of
our dark age people but uh they were
pretty dark ages
and uh yes there were some there was the
church which was a civilizing influence
and there were some things left over
from the roman empire which had fallen
but generally speaking life in the dark
ages was
nasty and and barbaric and short and
certainly a lot less pleasant
than it had been during the roman era
that had preceded it which had been a
far more
civilized era with with you know better
government and
better hygiene and um you know
more of the trappings of what we would
consider the civilization
uh when the roman empire fell the human
race really did
go back um or at least western i mean
let's
let's be clear here that um there were
things going on in
in the americas and in africa and then
certainly in
asia with chinese completely unrelated
to what was happening during the dark
ages and
in western europe but still the dark
ages were a
bad period and then we climbed out of it
into the into the middle ages but it was
still a
difficult time and it was you know the
black death would come along every once
in a while and
kill three quarters of the people and
the
systems of justice and and uh
were primitive and and did not really
work for many people i mean if there was
the class system
um had real teeth if you were a lord you
could get away with all sorts of rape
and murder
on on people of lower classes of you
know peasants and
surfs and things like that they didn't
have much appeal and practicality they
may have had certain rights
in theory but try to exercise them and
it was very difficult it was a period of
there were frequent famines and
starvation and
most people were illiterate um the
the serfs were in the early ages were
attached to land and even when they
weren't attached to land they
lived and died in their own little
village like the next village three
miles down the road was like a foreign
country to them
let alone the only time they really got
to see the world is when there was a war
and
i think one of the reasons that people
at least at first eagerly would sign up
when the king said hey
let's we're going to go to france and
have war against the frenchmen and
hey well get to see france and maybe get
some plunder and
you know get out of this planting the
turnips and harvesting the turnips and i
wonder the crusades were so popular
a lot of your characters seem very
lonely to me in the book do you think
we're all a bit like that
i'm sure i think that's uh
maybe that's just my world view but
there's a certain existential loneliness
right we're all trapped in our own
in our own heads i you know i in my
early work
long before ice and fire i wrote science
fiction from the 70s
and i had a story my first hugo and
nebula award winner the song for liar
was about telepathy and that was always
an interesting issue to explore in
science fiction was
what if you could really know uh another
human being
you know what if you could read their
minds not just some
treatments of telepathy it's just like
silent conversation where
you know you're just reading thoughts
that people are sending to you but what
if you could really go in someone's head
and know all their secrets know
everything about them every good thing
about them every shameful thing about
them all the
all the fears that they have all the
desires that they have all of the
the terrible things that they've done or
wish they'd done or or
or dreams would you would it make you
love other people more
would there be total acceptance if you
had total knowledge of another person
or would you get mad would you hate
everybody else and
would they all hate you because we would
all see i mean we're all these
complex combinations of uh of good and
evil um
but we have walls that we erect and we
we only show
other people the things that we want
them to see and there's a certain
existential loneliness
you know because of the very nature of
that